et maintenant retrouvons une nouvelle
histoire de papi
grenier encore une fois des voitures ont
été détruites dans la baranlieu de Paris
par des groupes de jeunes en kimono la
c'est japonais quelle bande de RAC PAP
PAP PAP coucou papi oh les enfants oh
toujours là quand j'ai pas envie de voir
papi papi tu nous racontes une histoire
ah une histoire est-ce que je vous ai
raconté quand j'ai ouvert la mer Rouge
que j'ai guidé les Juifs à travers le
désert mais papi tu as jamais fait ça et
qu'est-ce que tu en sais d'abord hein oh
et puis merde écoutez regardez la télé
plutôt il y a un reportage qui va parler
de moi c'était en
1998 le monde était dangereux à l'époque
nous sommes dans la ville de Hou le
vendredi soir tout paraî calme mais sous
cette apparente tranquillité se cache en
fait un malaise dormant qui atteint
toute la cité ouais toute la Cé en cause
cet homme son vrai nom est link mais
pour des raisons d'anonymat nous allons
masquer son visage et l'appeler Sabrina
nous avons recueilli une série de
témoignages prouvant que Sabrina est à
l'origine de bien des problèmes Mojo est
un arbre et il connaît Sabrina pour des
raisons d'anonymat il tient à porter une
perruque oh oui j'adore faire entrer des
petits garçons à l'intérieur de mon
corps je fait rentrer plein de choses
des araignées des clés un donjon tout
entier et puis je leur donne mes noirs
les petits enfantsor mes noirs notre
interview est brutalement interrompu par
l'arrivée des gendarmes bonjour monsieur
brigade des mineurs veuillez me suivre
s'il vous plaît vous ne m'attraperez
jamais
e merde nous n'en saurons pas plus notre
quête de vérité se poursuit vers le sud
près du lac il a nous y rencontrons un
homme son nom est pêcheur pour des
raisons de vie privée il ne tient pas à
nous révéler son vrai métier pourquoi il
essayé de pêcher dans l'aquarium
pourquoi il y a un laimence là juste à
côté plein de poissons pourquoi il
essayé choper le le petit poisson dans
l'aquarium et pourquoi il Essé de Me
pêcher à moi hein pourquoi je comprends
pas
link Sabrina a eu une considérable
influence sur hule mais qui était
vraiment Sabrina nous avons rencontré la
personne qu'il a le plus côtoyé ah bah
au début cétait bien j'avoue quand on
s'est rencontré au début j'ai eu un peu
peur hein wink je voulais te dire c'est
gentil de m'avoir sauvé
merci il ramenait plein de rubies à la
maison il faisait du jardinage veuxtu
voilà bon il était un peu bizarre des
fois quand on se retrouvé tous les deux
dans l'
privé bon alors tu vienes qu'est-ce que
tu regardes
là non Franch au début c'était bien hein
mais après quand on a commencé à avoir
des problèmes de couple là il y a plus
personne hein link c'est trop c'est trop
c'est trop j'en ai assez on ne peut
jamais parler avec toi hein oh en plus
tu vas faire un peu le ménage et moi
j'en ai marre et tes affaires le
traînent partout tous les temps oh tu me
parles pas comme ça hein et puis tu r
ton Carina là qu'est-ce que tu vas faire
reste ici tu restes ici je te dis oh
ouais c'est ça ouais va picoler va
picoler ouais c'est ça ouais c'est ça
mais casse-toi casse-toi de toute façon
moi j'étais plus heureuse au S toi
ilrogne
ilrogne et vous qu'est-ce que vous
filmez làha hein qu'est-ce qu'il y a
vous barrez-vous barrez-vous barrez-vous
non mais Franch [ __ ] de merde je suis
une princesse ou je suis pas une
princesse oui oui ce Carina je te jure
je le prends je vais te lui enfoncer
dans
le mon petit depuis que Link a battu
Ganon c'est horrible il arrête pas
d'utiliser son noarina pour remonter le
temps et faire n'importe quoi pour
modifier
l'histoire vraiment super
lour quoi il a recommencé c'est
ça
mer je te jure il est chiant avec ce
[ __ ] de Karina il est vraiment super
chiant il peut faire pleuvoir et il fait
n'importe quoi avec le temps vous croyez
que ça nous affecte pas quand il fait
ça je vais le tuer je vous jure que je
vais le
tuer je sais plus je sais plus quel jour
on est papi pourquoi il utilisit tout le
temps un nookarina
Link tu trouves pas que ce serait un peu
bizarre
autrement écoutez euh à vrai dire j'en
ai marre que les gens me prennent pour
un mec méchant je sais pas pourquoi mais
mais mais tout le monde interprète mal
ce que je
dis euh vous promet les
ténèbres ouis on voit que d ici faud un
peu quand même changer le VO vous allez
mourir vous allez mourir de froid mettez
ce mteau enfin mon petit et puis merde
c'est pas parce que le Link il m'a vu
une fois en contreplongé à un soir
d'orage que ça fait de moin un mec
méchant
okarina cocotte agressée nuisance
nocturne tel est le lot quotidien du
village Cocorico pourtant il existe une
personne qui a su tirer son épingle du
jeu moi ça va bien je l'adore ce type je
l'adore je t'adore toi depuis que tu s
roule que tu rentres chez les gens que
tu casses la poterie moi j'ai touché les
factctol c'est bien franchement je te
remercie j'ai emborché 200 personnes
j'ai fait 400000 rubes de bénéfice tout
va bien il est 14h tandis que la nuit
tombe sur hule notre enquête est à
présent terminée le calme revient sur la
plaine bercé par les cris de Sabrina
demain sera une autre journée une autre
aventure après notre reportage la
situation de hu a évolué le vendeur
d'hiru ne changea rien à son commerce et
continua à vendre des bombes à des
jeunes enfants l'Arbre Mojo a été
incarcéré à domicile sous surveillance
électronique la princesse Zelda s'est
refiancée avec le potier parce que je
cite lui au moins il est riche et c'est
pas un trou du cul Kaepora le hibou on
monté une nouvelle émission nommée
Kaepora le grand frère où il donne des
conseils aux gens link a revendu Epona à
une boucherie chevaline pour s'acheter
un scooter puis disparu nous sommes sans
nouvelles de lui à ce
Ganondorf est devenu président de l'ONG
gerouo sans frontière quant au Goron ils
ont été chassés de leur montagne après
une descente de la brigade destup 800 kg
de cailloux ont été
saisis papi cette histoire s bien
terminé au moins
oui non Linka je vais te renvoyer dans
le passé afin que tu puisses vivre une
Fance heureuse
papi raconte-nous encore une
histoire bien sûr mais ça sera pour la
prochaine
fois les enfants
oh c'est quoi le
texte regarde-moi ça link
link pour moi ça va bien ça va bienadore
ce
type comme la
M je suis je peux faire
Ganon
SC les
j vous allez
mourir j'ai une
la dommage que tu te sois
Maré ça fonctionne du
tonner j'ai embossé 200 personnes fa
400 la tartine dans la
gueule 1 2 3 arrête de
Mar c'est
trop tropop